Hey guys welcome back, thanks for joining us today on the king of random in the past
We've done several experiments with dry ice and we've had two viewers
Give us suggestions of other things to try with the dry ice Daniel milage ask
How does liquid nitrogen compare to a cooling bath of acetone and dry ice?
YouTube user like 'whoa says put dry ice in your backyard foundry so like whoa and Daniel mileage today
we're going to be doing two experiments using extreme heat and extreme cold the first thing we're gonna try is using some dry ice and
Acetone to make a supercooled liquid that you can use for some experiments if you're having a hard time getting some liquid, nitrogen
Dry ice is extremely cold, it's approximately 100 9.3
degrees Fahrenheit below zero
Acetone doesn't freeze until one hundred thirty nine degrees Fahrenheit below zero so we can put dry ice in acetone it will
Supercool the liquid down to the temperature of the dry ice but it won't freeze we don't just want to mix the two together
So first we're going to use this cup to create a barrier between the acetone and the dry ice for a first step
Let's take a drill and poke some holes in our cup
I poked a lot of holes into this cup because I want the acetone to be able to flow in and out of it easily
Next we're gonna break up some of the dry ice and spread it all around the outside of the cup
All right now load these all up all around our cup
Our glass bowl is whining
That's the the dry is vibrating in very small movements all around the glass
Just sounds like it's complaining
The next step is to pour your acetone down into the bowl
And it should fill the cup as well as all the way around the dry-ice
Force them directly into the cup to make sure it's getting in there
You go lots of bubbling going on I'm gonna try adding a little bit more dry ice as well
Some of it seems to have a sublimed off from the heat of the acetone
All right now we have a bath of extremely cold acetone
That's fun and in the middle because we have the holes in the cup
We have a spot that doesn't have any dry ice in it
So we don't have to worry about whether things are coming in contact with the dry ice all right watch
What happens when I stick the tip of my glove into the acetone?
That's very very cold it actually makes the Nitro of my glove get a little bit stiff just from freezing it so much
Let's see what happens if we freeze a carrot
Please note never use this cold acetone bath on anything you're going to eat acetone is toxic and not safe for consumption
All right care it into extremely cold acetone this acetone should be about a hundred and nine degrees below zero Fahrenheit
Here goes
It's boiling in a similar manner to the liquid nitrogen when you pour it in the heat from the carrot is
Heating up the acetone quite a bit. Hopefully the dry ice is keeping it nice and cold
Set that in there for a minute
All
Right our carrot looks pretty good and frozen
What I'm going to do at this point is take it out and smash it with a hammer to see if it shatters the way
We expect a really frozen piece of produce to do quickly before I try that let's make it control by smashing an unfrozen carrot 3
That kind of exploded a little bit more than I expected it to carrots aren't super squishy, so I guess it makes sense
We've tried smashing the unfrozen carrot. Let's see how the frozen carrot handles listen to that
That is not the sound of normal carrot 3 2 1 oh
My gosh
That is a very
Frozen carrot, holy cow that sent shards. I mean the other the unfrozen carrot like broke apart would this like
explode listen to that
That's a carrot it's shattered to I heaven right there bluey
Is ice carrot
Now we know what happens if you freeze a carrot in acetone
That's over a hundred degrees below zero next I want to try and experiment with a rubber band
When rubber gets too cold, it loses its elasticity meaning it won't stretch out
But it also means if it is stretched out it won't contract back in and that's what we're gonna try and do today
What I'm gonna
Do is take this rubber band fit it on the end of the bamboo skewer and stretch it out and while it's stretched
I'm going to dip it into our freezing cold acetone. Let's see what happens a
little bits of carrot floating around in there, but that shouldn't cause any
That's probably pretty good and cold already it stopped bubbling let's take it out and see what happens if I like over the river band
Look at that the stretched out portion is staying stretched out
And then as it warms back up it regains its elasticity as it warms back up this time
I'm gonna see if I can pull the rubber band out and
Immediately try and bend it and see if it will break in theory
It should be able to get cold enough for that but it might just warm up too fast
And I'm not able to get it alright. Let's see what I can do here
There it goes
Snapped a rubber band in half and now it's already warmed up enough that it's starting to be stretchy again. Let's try that again
Broken I think at this point the responsible thing to do is to put the whole rubber band ball in and see what happens
Hopefully the acetone is getting in between the rubber bands and down into the middle so it's really freezing it all the way through
Alright, let's see if I can take this out and see if it has any bounce left to it at all I bet it doesn't
really have any
That sounded like a rock put this back in for just a second case. It's warmed up then we're gonna try hitting with a hammer
One two three well
Bits of it broke off I did shatter some parts you can see little
destroyed bits of
Rubber band just sort of sitting around their impact marks with a hammer hit, and I think as this warms up
this is gonna start peeling away a lot more as
One last experiment with our freezing cold acetone and dry ice I'm gonna see what happens if I pour a little bit of water into
It genuinely have no clue what to expect here
So I think the water dispersed in the acetone, but it also froze
So I'm pretty sure what we're seeing there are tons of separated individual little ice crystals in a pour some more in
That just kind of builds up on the sides here weird slushy
I'm guessing that's a mix of acetone and water
It certainly smells like a stone wool
That is spraying everywhere isn't it?
Now we've tested making a cooling bath that takes acetone down to over a hundred degrees below zero
Let's see what happens if we take dry ice and put it in our backyard foundry dry ice is composed of carbon dioxide
So it's possible that as it heats up and starts turning into a gas it will put out the flame
That's one of the things you're gonna find out, and if it doesn't put out the flame
Let's see what it will do
Our foundry is nice, and hot let's see what happens when we put in our dry ice
Looking at it so far. It's smaller
It's still extremely cold of course
Other than that it doesn't look like it's doing anything really special from the heat
The fire in the Forge doesn't seem to be affected by the carbon dioxide
I think that there's enough flow from the pressure of the propane that it just blows any excess carbon dioxide right out the top
Let's see if it makes any difference to put the lid on
There's our dry ice down in the foundry with the lid on it looks like it's glowing orange, but I'm almost positive
That's just from the ambient light lighting it up
Well there it is it hasn't seemed to change much
Except that it's smaller so I'd say the heat does make it dissipate faster, but
Nothing else is really happening to it
Well, I'm going to try something else
I'm going to try heating up these tongs until they're glowing red hot and then touch that directly to the dry ice
All right, let's see what happens
Well not a lot really
Not a lot happened, I thought it would do a lot more
I thought the red-hot metal might melt its way through the dry ice kind of like it does with normal ice
But it just cool off the metal and barely left a dent in the dry ice
Let's throw the rest of it in see what happens
Well all of our dry ice is gone
It didn't put out the flame it didn't put off a lot of vapors like it doesn't put it in hot water
It just sort of sublimated into nothingness that whole block took about 10 minutes to disappear in our furnace
Which is much faster than if you just left it sitting on the counter, but it's not very enjoyable
After pouring all of that water into our supercooled acetone bath something interesting has happened. It's turned into a slush
So I think this is about half water and half acetone
So I'm going to scoop it out put it on a brick and light it on fire
Not entirely sure what's making it bubble like that here goes
Oh, it's actually on fire. It's just acetone burning so it's very clear. It's hard to see
Well that is burning right now
Burning snow. You don't see that every day
It's still really cold it's on fire, but it's freezing cold like if I touch part of it
It's very cold to the touch, but it's on fire
It's freezing cold and on fire at the same time that was freezing my hand and burning my hand
Different parts of my finger at the same time. Oh and now our acetone is all just running off and pouring off and
We've used this brick for some colored smoke powder before and the acetone has been pulling that off of the brick
And so we're getting this pink stain as it runs
There you have it two experiments using dry ice one a method of making an extremely cold liquid bath using
Acetone the other putting dry ice into our backyard foundry with the acetone bath
we were able to supercool rubber and produce and both of them became very brittle and
Lost all their elasticity when they were completely frozen in the acetone with the dry ice in the foundry it turned into gas
Faster than it normally would if it were just sitting out on the counter
But it wasn't really very entertaining nothing spectacular happened the co2 wasn't enough to put out the fire. It just kind of
Disappeared a special shout-out to Daniel mileage and likewho for your suggestions on what we should try check your youtube inbox
We're sending you 25 bucks if you have any ideas for any
Experiments or projects you want us to try let us know down in the comments if we end up using your idea will send you
25 dollars acetone is easily available at most hardware stores, so this is an experiment you probably can try at home
Just be sure you wear protective gloves and eyewear at all times
Thanks for joining us today for these projects and we look forward to the next one talk to you then
It's bouncy again, this is cleanup
Don't let on fire
Three two one hang on I'm going to put my safety glasses on
Hey guys
Did you know that we're on Twitter Instagram and Facebook as well all at the king of random and every platform has a different purpose
So go scroll through the histories check out what we're doing. I'll see you there